il y a un an le visage dolena devenait
le symbole de la guerre la photo de son
visage ensanglanté a fait la une des
journaux partout dans le monde où
lendemain de l'invasion récent Ukraine
je n'ai jamais pensé qu'une telle chose
pouvait arriver je n'ai jamais pensé que
cela arriverait vraiment dans cette vie
confiait-elle à l'époque en état de choc
un an plus tard elle se rappelle ses
premières heures de la guerre
à la première explosion j'ai tout de
suite compris que c'était le début de la
fin et dit-elle aujourd'hui réfugiés en
Pologne elle travaille avec une
psychologue pour tenter de surmonter un
syndrome de choc post-traumatique si son
corps a été réparé grâce à de nombreuses
chirurgies son esprit lui demeure marqué
parce qu'elle a vécu
la première chose que j'ai vu en sortant
de chez moi dit-elle c'est le corps de
mon jeune voisin étendu par terre il
était mort son père pleurait à côté de
lui je n'oublierai jamais cette image
devenir le visage de la guerre a aussi
été difficile
j'ai aussi dû faire face à des critiques
sur internet de la part de russe qui
disait que c'était une mise en scène que
tout cela n'existait pas
un an plus tard cette guerre est
malheureusement encore bien réelle
malgré tout Léna ne rêvent que d'une
chose pouvoir un jour entrer en Ukraine
ici lise Villeneuve Radio-Canada
Montréal